hey man get ready for film school
fridays where i'm just gonna talk about
filmmakers and the movies they make that
i love every week and uh with uh with
jake with luke
uh with vinnie with my friends i'm
saying them like they're rock stars they
will be by the time you listen to this
goddamn podcast but
uh
if you want to hear more of that kevin
smith and who the [ __ ] doesn't wanna uh
if you're like my mother and you're like
my god i can't get enough of this guy's
voice
come on join us over at that kevin smith
club man
thatkevinsmithclub.com i do a morning
show five days a week wake and bake man
where i just literally wake up smoke
weed and just talk at you and [ __ ]
uh if if you're looking to throw a few
uh bucks my way for this free podcast
you're about to enjoy
jump on over to that kevin smith club uh
and join up right now man be a clerk i'm
all right a fun employee or a yoga hose
that's right i made the highest level
[ __ ] my least popular movie that's
how i roll
thatkevinsmithclub.com ladies and
gentlemen and now the debut of film
school fridays
class is in session for film school
fridays man i'm your host kevin smith
i'm jake s weissman so jake uh works uh
with me here at uh the office and um him
and luke are huge [ __ ] movie nerds
kind of like myself
and uh part of the joy of uh
working in uh
in business is is uh
it attracts people that like the things
that you like
about a medium right i mean there are
people out there who are just like i'm
in it for the [ __ ] drugs and the dick
and the [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] but
you meet people that i tend to meet them
uh and work with them uh who are there
for the passion nobody would mind
getting rich but everyone's there first
and foremost because
they love film as a medium film has
changed their lives touched their lives
that's their
the parlance in which they speak um the
preferred currency in which they trade
so
the uh
you know the older one gets uh
the more
one especially when you're a creator you
make a bunch of [ __ ] and
you
you know you d i deep dive on pop
culture you know on fat man beyond
particularly on like the marvel movies
and stuff
but uh you know before there were marvel
movies
which what a dark time it was
there were you know
i had to like other things
and i was just a fan of cinema
in general and i think i pretty much
still am obviously but
the original incarnation of the show is
we talked to kids who were actually in
[ __ ] film school and stuff and uh not
just kids but like adults and whatnot
but uh for this incarnation we're just
gonna talk [ __ ] movies it's kind of
you know [ __ ] about flex for example
is born out of discussion that jake and
i had
maybe yesterday about
uh paul tom sanderson's latest movie
yeah
uh licorice pizza
if you haven't seen it
see it it's going to be up for all sorts
of awards
this year
jake is a big pta guy correct yes
and in order for a podcast to work
you're gonna go deeper than one-word
responses my friend
otherwise i might as well be alone here
yes kevin i very much like pta i've been
uh following him
uh since i mean my first one in the
theater was punch drunk love because i
was 15 years old had you seen boogie
nights prior to that you know what i
don't know if i had seen it but i was a
big fan of drew scriptarama as a kid so
when i remember that site right so yeah
they had the dogma script yep back in
the early night all your [ __ ] man yeah
yeah before that was how i mean i i
never blame that first i thought it was
cool i was like oh my god somebody gives
a [ __ ] about a movie i haven't made yet
uh and where'd they get that script
right but then like the religious people
used that script and that site yeah to
attack us i remember one guy
particularly like was like we read the
script on drew scriptorama
and jeruscriptorama kids i don't know if
they still exist if they do god bless
them but like
drew script orama existed on the
internet
at a time
when you could be like oh i did the
internet it was fun
and hit you literally meant you hit
every [ __ ] site it was like binging
on a television show you're like i had
every website it was [ __ ] great uh
what next so they were early
adapters of of the medium and early
movie buffs right going like hey man
here's this amazing communication tool
we're going to use it
to [ __ ] put scripts up because we're
script [ __ ] nerds so i spent a lot of
time on that site and i was a filmmaker
by the time that site launched it wasn't
like i was a young neophyte hoping to
get into the business i was already
[ __ ] a bonafide filmmaker sure i
would still go to that site to read john
hughes scripts because i had never had
access to a john hughes brothers or
scripts or alien like i mean it's the
only way to get better right and to read
other people's stuff and nowadays that's
[ __ ] simple like you know you can
google somebody's script you can buy a
book you go to library like you can
see any screenplay one sometimes you get
to read a script before the movie even
[ __ ] comes out
um but back then
you did not have access like i remember
the way that i accessed scripts back in
the day was if i went to a comic con
there'd be invariably one dealer
with a box of [ __ ] scripts like
that's how i read silence of the lands
before the movie came out that's where i
got a batman three script by
by um what are their names the [ __ ]
two people that wrote unforgiven and
then the movie didn't wind up happening
really oh with the [ __ ] it had maltese
[ __ ] penguins in it like that was the
mystery at the core
um and then they canceled that movie so
like i used to buy scripts at cons and
then drew scriptarama introduced us to
the notion of like oh here here's a
place and then many people
you know i'm not gonna say they [ __ ]
copied him but they came after him and
did the same thing putting up scripts
and whatnot sure but what a glorious
time you just talking back to all right
so you read
i'm a very specific age yeah where
so i'm born in 87
which means i want to watch r-rated
movies and i'm not necessarily allowed
to so before i watched clerks i read it
on imdb quotes
and we were like what a weird way to
consume the movie and me and my friend
dave that's what we would do we'd sit
there and just laugh jizz mopper oh my
god we're [ __ ] 12 like in many ways
it's
preferable to looking at clerks because
when you see the words on the imdb
they're clean
you know presented on the same
background as everybody else and so
you're judging them literally just on
those words then the moment a picture
gets in that's what gives [ __ ]
a chance to be like this ain't cinnamon
i'll know that
[ __ ] that it's you know but what a weird
you're the first person i've ever met
who's like i got into clerks through the
quotes
i got into clerks to be fair
because
a the clerk's trailer was on something
pulp fiction
i wasn't watching pulp fiction though so
like i don't know what
miramax flick or whatever i was watching
maybe like
maybe it was on some coen brothers movie
or something you know what i mean like i
have no idea
um
and then my older sister hannah
is just the right age to be like
because she is born in 77 so she's 10
years older than me and i remember her
talking about your stuff and like
your stuff is
the naughtiest of the naughty like it's
the it's the most insane it's so weird
to think about so soft now
uh but wait let's keep it on pta so when
so what's your first experience with pta
then you're essentially what jake's
getting at
and we'll learn more about jake as the
show proceeds um
is you were a film buff
and you were not able to go see
some of the paul thomas anderson cannon
in theaters based on your age right and
the first one you did go see was
glove yeah but when did you [ __ ] with
the other ones like when did you see a
boogie knight's a hard 8 ate magnolia
it took me a long time to see hard eight
i remember a friend my age saw magnolia
and told me about it and i was
fascinated by the idea so we rented it
and i watched it with my folks and i
think i was 12
or something like that it's r but i
wouldn't call it a hard arm but it's a
it's an a it's an adult yeah you know
like the stuff that tom cruise is
talking about the whole i mean all of it
is just like respect the [ __ ] right i
used to work at that that's right you
had to sit in front of your parents
while tom cruise said tame the [ __ ]
yes sir they're like we're turning this
off and my mother
you know my mom doesn't [ __ ] like
uh like i can't handle the truth that's
a completely different time totally
different and it's also like it's a
three-hour movie yeah you know
i i rem
i don't want to go too off topic but i
remember being 14 years old and being
like dad can we please rent pie
and then we watch pie together and he's
like oh you like the artsy fart [ __ ] and
i was just like you did like the rt
fortune i mean i was young and it
struck me it is a nearly impenetrable
movie
for those that really aren't into math
whatsoever no it's about
like bible codes yeah and manipulating
the
economy for god
that's really cool
i'm not saying it's not cool but like
of all of his stuff what's his name
darren arnosky um that you know that was
the breakout right but probably the
least accessible maple has a hard time
with the fountain maybe even more so
than
than mother i still haven't seen mother
i i mean you know this is where a bunch
of people [ __ ] like hang up on this
podcast like [ __ ] him he's an idiot i
enjoyed it
[ __ ] so ballsy
like incredibly involved yeah it was
like you know i i'm not i
i don't have to defend the storytelling
he you know it's his movie his story but
in terms of like presentation in terms
of like execution
in terms of like sheer [ __ ] like [ __ ]
there's
that's that's a movie no one's ever
gonna [ __ ] make
except him right that definitely [ __ ]
uh takes the cake but you're right
fountain is a pretty i don't know the
fountain to me was more accessible it's
like all right
same guy many times i think
i love the fountain very very much
um
i'm one of those guys that cares more
about his esoteric [ __ ] from the
beginning than like the wrestler
or black swan
um
there's something about the fountain
where i'm like this is just
i've tried i remember being in age where
i was trying to write scripts
and every single time it would just end
up being the mountains
[Laughter]
you're like i'm going after that
fountain audience and they're like what
the only problem with the fountain is
that it's 100
humorless
and uh
i appreciate humorless films but i don't
[ __ ] with me and luke we're just talking
about that like definitely defining
comedy versus drama you're absolutely
right it's humorless but i would say
it's earnest oh my god that like that
that's a 100 percent it's like
it's like when you you know you meet
people in life and some people are like
hey man come seek himself whatever [ __ ]
it happens man you know [ __ ]
day late the dollar short like that kind
of
and then they're you know the oscar
madisons yeah and then there are the
felix ungers
type personalities and stuff and you
know who are like very fastidious and
like no this is this and that is that
and everything has its place and this is
a presentation
that's you know
darren aronofsky chris nolan to me yeah
i'm definitely more of the oscar madison
school of like you know i probably
shouldn't be here and stuff i'm throwing
spaghetti against the wall
uh not only to see what sticks but to
dry it as well but and those cats are
you know keeping the apartment neat
enough
it's two different things because most
people listening are like bro you're not
even in the apartment i would feel like
an oscar disagree
you're [ __ ] uh you're their buddy
from down the street or a cop friend or
a guy who popped by for what episode
you're the gateway drug dude you're the
guy
you're the [ __ ]
you're the guy who gets you in
and then
you know there's something to be said
for these incredible frames these guys
that want to be kubrick i get it i get
it i get it i'm in hal ashby guy i'm a
john cassavetes guy john cassavetes just
turned on the [ __ ] camera and made it
and so
it's
it's just two different ways of going
about it truth i feel like licorice
pizza
goes more cassavetes
than
um
than like just these incredible shots i
think he does a good i think i like his
movies because he feels that [ __ ] out
and he likes just kind of the look of
things he uses i don't know we agree on
certain um like production design
choices and [ __ ] i like that bare white
brick that uh cooper hoffman's sitting
in when he's waiting for the cops you
know like there's just something about
that that's very 70s about it that shot
at the beginning where he's
he's just like just following them that
opening shot is [ __ ] nuts this oddly
enough like when i think of paul's stuff
you know i think of um
i think of films that are very
um
composed sure
um you know
sometimes the moving shots whip pan into
a push and stuff like that
sometimes a long push in
um as in tom cruise and magnolia when
he's just like i'm i'm quietly judging
you and you just watched magnolia get
into that don't don't [ __ ] leave
don't
like get to the part where you watch
magnolia i just it's it's if you've just
watched it i just literally watched it
so it is um what was i talking about
though [ __ ]
um he's very composed very composed um
this licorice pizza
felt you know more
off the cuff i noticed he was one of the
dps yeah he started doing that with
phantom thread so
that means he's running around with a
camera on shoulders this movie is
incredibly under lit
or it's incredibly lit and then in post
they [ __ ] it everything they i don't
mean [ __ ] it up but they muted it and
made it look like a 70s movie and stuff
but it did have a more visceral
from the hip
doc you feel the whole time i was
watching it
it's probably because it's set in the
valley but it's also because of the look
and it's also because of the almost
documentary nature of the film
all i could think about was one of my
favorite films in the entire world the
bad news bears
which was set two years three years
after
licorice pizza pizza was set butt shot
in the real 70s
pta makes a movie that looks like it
could have been on a double bill
or playing not a double bill but same
[ __ ] a drive-in one at seven o'clock
one at nine o'clock yeah it looks like a
seventies movie sometimes you get these
filmmakers who are like who fetishize
yes making the thing look like the thing
you're like we just made clerks three
and in clerks three they make clerks
right so like at points we make a black
and white present day version of an old
movie blah blah blah
you know and and leron rdp was like all
right man like what you want to [ __ ]
do with the footage from when you want
to make it talking about doing some cool
technical [ __ ] to it
and i was like that's just if it's black
and white that's fine
and he's like yeah but the grain and all
that and i'm like it it really doesn't
matter
[Laughter]
now to a real filmmaker that kind of
[ __ ] would matter that'd be that'd be
part of it like oh they'd be like oh
that [ __ ] that's but you would have
talked about that before you shot it
yeah right oh yeah it's not like
i didn't drop a bomb on him in post
it was in pre right when i was like well
no that won't be needed yeah i was like
we'll just shoot on red and take the
couple i see he actually wanted to shoot
on film film or well there was at one
point a discussion about that and i got
a buddy works at kodak uh who's always
like
you gotta join me
and chris
quentin and paul and you know do the
film thing yes and then he made a really
decent pitch this time around because he
was just like um
they're shooting a fake movie in the
movie just shoot the fake movie on on
film on kodak right
which would have made sense if the movie
was set in the 90s right
set where it is there's no way those
dudes would ever make the more expensive
choice
to shoot a film you know randall's 50
almost so he's not like a
18 to 23 year old kid who's like you
know we got [ __ ] shoot film right
this is a guy who just lived through a
heart attack and he's just making he's
happy he's making a movie at all
the fact that they're using a red camera
like is even far-fetched
that's true you know what i'm saying
where are these [ __ ] gonna get black
magic pocket probably god probably or a
[ __ ] that's what i tried my [ __ ]
look an iphone is gonna look silly like
these guys are making a movie let's give
them a camera
so they gotta they got a camera so i
can't then take that image shot on a red
and everybody sees the red who knows
what a red is like oh i know what the
image of a red camera looks like we're
already cheating by being like here's
your camera pov and it's black and white
which is not the way it is
in real life
so you know you're using cinematic
language to tell a [ __ ] story
that's big enough that that is lying
enough for me right i don't need to then
be like like at one point leroy was like
there's a ten thousand dollar process
that we could put this through where
it'll really look like the clerk's
footage but i'm like but that wouldn't
make sense as much as i would love that
that wouldn't make sense because they're
making a movie in 20 [ __ ] 21 right
and
you know if your red camera gave you an
image of what you're talking about we
should produce you'd throw it out or
you'd be like give me a new camera
broken there's something wrong with it i
was like if we just get to black and
white alone this story's done
so that's me as the filmmaker and that's
not just lays i'm like that's just
practical
paul is the filmmaker particularly in
this instance where he's like i'm going
to make a thing that looks like the
thing yeah so it's not only going to be
set in that era
and have the vibe of that era and the
production design is going to look like
that era
it's going to look like literally you
saw it in that era
commit committing to like
when i make a flick i talk about how the
story doesn't begin when the movie
starts or end when the credits roll
story begins now like as i keep talking
about clerks 3 long before anybody sees
it and stuff and then the story never
ends because i'll be talking about
clerks three till the day i die same way
i've been talking about all the other
[ __ ] movies i make it's up to you the
storyteller to keep that [ __ ] story
going
what it occurs to me
like paul was doing is is a kind of
version
of the same uh but not you know the way
i do it where i'm online hyping it up
and [ __ ] like that
um [ __ ] i lost the thread of the phantom
thread two stone god i had a good point
oh well that's good let's get the
experience of licorice pizza like
because he did the pop-up he did um he
kept it a real secret and changed the
title and all this stuff um
and then really made it an experience
his rollout
was pretty cool this year i mean look if
you live out here
and you're anywhere near the valley yeah
you would think this movie was [ __ ]
star wars
the amount of billboards uh as as jake
mentioned there's a pop-up they did a
fat bernie's uh pinball pinball emporium
uh as a pop-up right on i think ventura
right next to the theater um you know
they're
mgm i think they're putting it out and
spending some [ __ ] money and even the
movie is is gonna
definitely make get awards i think it's
doing well at the box office right now
it's a movie that could actually
cross over like to a mainstream audience
because it's like hey man love is love
don't matter whatever it's accessible
it is accessible
so
in a good way very good way
um so i that you know i got the oscar
screener for it and i was like all right
like i'm gonna watch this but before i
watched it you know i said to jenna i
was like you want to watch this the new
pta movie i was like it's all about the
valley
and that was jen's way and she's like
what
uh you know she just loves this area so
she's like oh i'd love to see movie set
in the valleys i set in the past dude
1973 so what
oh my god
and so i was like before we watch this
i think
i should go back
and watch magnolia
and she goes why and i was like i don't
i don't know it says two valley movies i
mean look [ __ ] boogie nights is a
valley movie as well but like
there it just feels like a part of a
thing yeah it is before i dive into this
i want to dive back into that because
historically for those that don't know
um one of my
my uh most
one of the stupidest things i've ever
done in this life
something a modern day kevin smith would
never do modern day kevin smith never
tells you what he isn't like tells you
screams from the rafters and cries about
what he likes and loves but we'll you'll
never hear like i [ __ ] hated that
it's a piece of [ __ ] it's a good mojo
there's no point you don't need to you
you want negativity [ __ ] open up
your laptop or your phone like there you
will find no end of people who want a
[ __ ] in the mouth of whatever [ __ ]
i'm just here to tell you about the [ __ ]
i like and stuff and i'll suffer in
silence with the things that i don't
[ __ ] like or i'll tell my loved ones
i got a wife you think i sit here and be
like are you [ __ ] kidding me with
this piece of [ __ ]
so you know and some people like well be
authentic i'm like it's not being
authentic to tell you the things i don't
like it's being an [ __ ] as far as i'm
concerned you don't need to know what i
don't know right especially if it's not
like you know like look
i went through four years of a
presidency where everybody in the world
was like shouting their displeasure and
[ __ ] and i'm like look i i get it but
like
i'm not gonna [ __ ] do the same thing
because
everyone knows i'm pretty liberal
or extremely [ __ ] liberal everyone
knows where i stand on the political
spectrum you don't need one more person
being like this [ __ ] sucks i'm gonna
try to be the person that's like
everybody here's what's cool or here's
what's good or here's something fun or
you know take your mind off this [ __ ]
how about this
um and sometimes that's about movies and
[ __ ] like that so
i'm i'm like you know
i
years ago
in 1999 when dogma came out it was the
same year magnolia came out
i was a big boogie nights fan which came
out
a couple years prior to that boogie
nights came out after clerks
new line put it out
but it was awesome somebody made a movie
about porn i was like it's [ __ ] nuts
and it was really good it's like a
altman type movie right
through in the world of porn
[ __ ] burt reynolds is made the whole
[ __ ] cast is amazing um you know
there's a whole scene where [ __ ]
john c reilly marky marco like how much
can you bench that was so [ __ ] real
like i've lived in that world man um
where guys said [ __ ] like that to each
other
so um and then that world happened to be
the world of porn and sex was treated so
[ __ ] casually and if you look at my
work obviously i'm a big fan of [ __ ]
sex
um to an almost infantile juvenile
degree
and here was a movie that like treated
sex so
in such a mundane fashion and in the
midst of it some people are able to find
love while [ __ ] you know it's
beautiful
so magnolia
is coming out and it's out and it's
getting blown everyone loves magnolia
and all the critics and this is [ __ ]
fantastic what a
what an achievement
and you know dogma was not getting the
same kind of love
and so there i there i was reading my
message board
um at viewskew.com and somebody was like
hey man what'd you think of magnolia or
something like that
and you know a modern day kevin smith
would just move the [ __ ] on you know
probably not even respond to that post
but [ __ ] young stupid juvenile
jealous
um
you know [ __ ] angry young man
[Music]
filmmaker
kevin smith who you know only
it was probably around the time he was
realizing oh
there are others like me
and they're way better at this than me
like
because for a year there i was the only
guy on the planet
doing no you know it was a weird
perspective and then suddenly i was
faced with like
you know
like i made a movie with [ __ ] huge
movie stars and it was massive and and
in terms of scope and story and [ __ ]
like the
certainly was no shrinking violet
[ __ ] world knew about the movie based
on the fact that religious people got
pissed about it and stuff
and you know i was like where's my oscar
[ __ ] talk like a jealous [ __ ]
yeah it's true i could say that now so
i respond to this person's
well i have this person go ahead before
you get into that good
you are also coming off of uh an indie
spirit award for chasing amy and writing
and i have something to do with it with
me thinking of awards and just kind of
being like where the [ __ ] am i in all of
this
me really it was like where am i how
come they're not [ __ ] talking about
awards for dogma that's what i was like
so like baffled by i'm like oh my god if
you gave me awards for clerks
and you know [ __ ] my mouth from all
right but you gave me awards for chasing
amy like dogma is like way bigger and
better than both of those films and that
was a young you know 29 year old [ __ ]
kevin smith
and don't get me wrong like dogma was
received incredibly well right
but when compared to somebody else
that's something
an older kevin smith would never do in
this day and age look over the fence
back then
i looked over the fence all the time
you're like what are they getting
right as opposed to just minding my own
business in my own backyard and enjoying
the fact that i got my own [ __ ]
backyard
instead i look over the fence and be
like what are they getting you know they
were i it was so [ __ ] stupid and you
know
crazy because we're all in a
creative business and we don't really
compete right
but i had people that i was like ooh it
burns
like he was my lex luthor
because so goofy right now bro for you
to say that right now that's the
goofiest [ __ ] bro
i these are things i could admit at age
51 but to be fair i've been admitting
these things since i was like 35 just
maybe haven't done a podcast about it
why did goodwill hunting fit into that
goodwill hunting was prior to that and
you know
i don't get jealous of good will hunting
because goodwill hunt i i mean your
name's on it and also like i'm the
bridge to it happening right so like
yeah it stinks when ben doesn't [ __ ]
thank me and scott when he when he wins
first the golden globe and the [ __ ]
oscar
but it's not like you know
that those pieces of [ __ ] like those are
my boys man i love that script
of chasing amy you're coming off of
goodwill hunting i was it's that's why
i'm sure some people listen like why the
[ __ ] would you think you made an awards
movie like i never thought i was an
awards person but my whole career
started with an awards movie clerks won
the filmmakers trophy sundance won the
pre-delaginess at cannes international
critics week at cannes
as mel as well as many other film
festival like [ __ ] awards and [ __ ]
like that uh maul rats obviously no just
got kicked in the nuts and wouldn't
[ __ ] become a thing for 10 years
um chasing amy though like gets a
standing ovation at [ __ ] sundance
joey gets nominated for a golden globe
uh my buddy who ran the [ __ ] academy
worked at the academy was like i i don't
know if i should tell you this
but i
i think you should know because i think
it would make you happy and i was like
all right and he was like you were one
slot away from best screenplay
and i was like get the [ __ ] out of here
he's like you had a lot of votes but
like you know the five that got him have
you ever said that before i think so
someplace
it's you know
what is that worth let's you know what
i'm saying
that's you don't tell that story because
it's like what kind of currency is that
i was like you know think about it this
way well think about it this way
what are the
how many you know they pick four or five
nominees right you and me
didn't make the list together
you know what i'm saying like [ __ ]
you we're in the same [ __ ] boat
except i made a whole ass movie
and didn't get a best screenplay
nomination you were what 12
and didn't get a best screenplay at
nomination but we're all equals when it
comes to that right so
i you know
the the i was in an awards world i
worked at miramax it was an awards
driven company and stuff that was also
branching over into the world of
commercial
so
you know dogma was
as we were making it it was financed
because it was like this is going to win
awards because and look at that cast and
blah blah
as you know the [ __ ] uh
year was ending and like all the chatter
was about magnolia and none of the
chatters about dogma and this person
asked this question on the viewscube
message board
instead of just like you know rolling on
this is i
you know what i should if i'm gonna do
it you can do it well if i should i
should get the exact quote rather than
[ __ ] uh
approximate it you know if i'm gonna
bite the bullet
kevin smith
paul
thomas
anderson you gotta i have a very
conflicted relationship with young kevin
smith he's my hero because he got me
here and look at the life i get to lead
but like
cringe bro
sometimes he says
[Laughter]
he says something i remember this who
the [ __ ] i remember this is when i
started getting into you so like i do
i had no skin in the game but i remember
this and maybe it's because of magnolia
fan
whatever and jay and silent bob strike
back
um
that made it go backwards to it and when
i you did you cemented it into the
viewers universe yes
and i did that and i wasn't like [ __ ]
you that was more that was me already
going
what an [ __ ] why is this
like oh my god
this apparently based on his
entertainment weekly article
um
it says updated january 27 2000.
so we came out
yes this is all tracks i was out here in
los angeles we were working on the
clerk's cartoon at this point
so
me
jen
and baby harley are living at this
rental place um
not too far from here actually
and then i'm going into
walt disney studios to work on clerk's
cartoon with dave mandel who now you
know went on and did veep and stuff like
that
um and scott and our and chris bailey
who is our lead animator
so
when i read this
i am reading the message board at this
rental place the guy's name was merrick
we were living at merrick's rental place
so i'm living at merrick's rental place
came home from working on the cartoon
um it's late december early january
or just early january it's gotta be
early january because we came out after
christmas so if this article is january
27th then it's gotta be somewhere around
there
and i read this [ __ ] thing and you
know this apparently
is what i write
ready
remember the question was this like
hey did you watch magnolia just simple
it wasn't like hey what it it wasn't hey
man can you [ __ ] burn magnolia for me
it was like literally like hey man you
watch it
this is what [ __ ] angry young kevin
smith wrote mind you with no good reason
to be angry he's getting everything he
wanted in life except the attention
that paul thomas anderson was getting
for his let's admit it far superior film
magnolia
here we go young kev smith get ready to
cringe my asshole's so tight
they sent me an academy screener dvd
this week
i'll never watch it again but i will
keep it
i'll keep it right on my desk as a
constant reminder that a bloated self
sense of self importance is the most
unattractive quality in a person
or their work
and then apparently i also likened it to
a cinematic root canal
whoa
whoa bro not only is it just like why
would you even [ __ ] bother saying
something but it's also like
you know
dude
you're punching way
too up
you know pick on someone your own size
this guy's a [ __ ] master of his art
at a young age and [ __ ] that sounds like
a reminder for me
is what i feel like like
don't don't forget about it you know but
it has nothing to do with magnolia it's
just like separate as a thought i mean
it was a complete overreaction magnolia
too because i did it's pretty mean it
was pretty and i did enjoy like uh like
lots of aspects of magnolia but
you know there i was and and it [ __ ]
lives out there forever and you can't
take it back like that [ __ ] you know
pwn tweet or whatever [ __ ] it it's just
yeah it's like herpes you carry it
forever
so
um you know and i've talked about many
times since then like what an idiot that
guy is meaning kevin smith
but i have never like went back and
re-watched magnolia maybe i did a few
years ago or something i think i did and
i was like yeah it works
but i i couldn't remember
much about other than tom cruise
and jason robards
and the frogs
which was where i was like you know and
also i think that's what like pushed me
over the edge where i'm like
all right so the [ __ ] frogs in this
movie
like people are talking about the
biblical [ __ ] i'm like i just made a
whole [ __ ] biblical movie [ __ ]
like he's got one scene with frogs i got
metatron you know what i'm saying so i
was competitive little bit [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so
so i you know i say to jen i'm like do
you remember anything about magnolia
she's like yeah a little bit but not a
lot i was like i feel like we should
watch that before we watch licorice
pizza
and she was like all right
and so we settled in to watch magnolia
which i forgot was a three hour motion
picture it's a long
it's an epic film it's big very big
um
and uh you know nobody's gonna be
surprised by this one iota
uh but i cried oh an awful lot an awful
lot i got so emotional i mean you got to
remember our dog marty
was doing the jason robards right at
that moment in time so there he is
laying in the bed dying by inches and
breaths yeah
and that's you know
i i didn't have the same relationship
with marty that uh jason robards or tom
cruise had with i hope not
with uh jason roberts but
when somebody yeah you know is dying in
front and stuff and there it is being
dramatized and
you know jason robards has a voice and
can tell you about his regrets and
you're just looking at the dog who's
like
he gives the most intense monologue i
haven't seen this movie in a very long
time and your the talks that we've had
i'm like i gotta put this in again
because there are some it's worth it
there's some weird subtle easter eggy
threads that go through it like the tail
of the worm like this whole thing that's
going on that are actually like deleted
scenes and
it's a very very epic cool
thing and i understand what you're
saying about like
why the religious aspects they're so
like
you know at the beginning of each act no
no
that's what young kevin smith said
ultra clear about that young please dude
young angry kevin smith
angry man
um
you know it's that fun stuff where
you know
i know how this will sound when me and
my best friend david
uh first got into clerks we were
watching it over and over again
and i specifically remember a sleepover
where we watched it
maybe the second or third time that
night
and we looked up we brought a dictionary
down and looked up every single word
and had a great time and i feel like
that's how i came up with those words
when i was driving when me and scott and
dave were driving into the city
to drop off the titles
to get made because you had to go to a
titles company and stuff now you just do
it on that avid right but back then you
had to deliver to titles company because
they would line up the writing and then
shoot it photograph it
so we were coming with all the credits
in that car ride is where we decided i
was the director
like i tried to pull scott into it i was
like why don't you be the co-director
and he's like because i didn't really do
that he's like you worked with the
actors and [ __ ] it was all your idea and
you framed it really he's going you know
i was like what about producer he's like
well all right yeah he's going i feel
like i produced scott had no idea what
his role
was on clerks while we were making it it
was ill-defined and then when we were
driving to the city
i was like
dave's role is very clear
cinematographer
my role was clear i'm the director but
i was like well scott you you were there
with me the whole time so aren't you
like co-director but scott's thing was
like i didn't
he worked with the actors for like a
month before i even got out there
i you know like i we shot everything the
way you wanted to shoot it
um he's gone you're the director okay um
so
how's this me i was always looking for a
friend
if you look at all the movies you know
dante randall jane salabah
[ __ ] holden
t.s and brody i was always just looking
for like that partner in [ __ ] crime
yeah so i was like be the [ __ ]
director with me and scott was wonderful
enough to be like look i want to be a
director but i did not direct this sure
um but i would like the producing credit
which he did
and backed into the role of producer
and did it for like [ __ ]
a dozen years yeah which was not his aim
he wasn't like i'm gonna go film school
produce movies let alone kevin smith
movies
um now we see he's directing like he
directed the grinch co-director
now he's about to do the [ __ ] weibo
movie for warner brothers i think he did
a fabulous documentary too oh he's big
in ducks and been in docks for a minute
death dock which is big
yeah and those guys i think it's lamb's
bread
um my brother like parties with those
dudes and all that [ __ ] yeah it's really
fun [ __ ] with you with the
connections why oh my god why are you
out here in hollywood bro and you're
[ __ ] connected in vermont oh my god
because i will always be you know bernie
yes do you i mean not personally but he
lived down the street for me
are you serious that ass yeah i've shook
his hand in my uh shule when i was a kid
he talked at my synagogue and i shook
his hand and then i'm being a facetious
[ __ ] here like i literally just lived
down the street from bernie sanders he
went to school with howard dean's kid
is a small place it's very small
and it's also like there's a city and
that's where i'm from what's the city
burlington yeah like the co-factory yeah
you got to get there man um
i've been in oh many times oh good i've
done shows there the last time i was
there was the reboot
tour oh you did that there beautiful i
believe so do you remember the if it was
at the flynn theater i can't remember
the venue okay
let's bring it back to pta so we're
gonna lose the audience like i don't
give a [ __ ] about kevin smith anyway
talk about vermont
some people are some people some people
will i mean someone is gigging out right
now right now they're just like oh my
god i too live down the street from
bernie sanders
um
so i uh i loved
magnolia
much much more
obviously than i did when i wrote those
things um back in in the year 2000 so 21
years later 20 you know almost 22 yeah
uh the brink of 22. i revisited the
movie and uh loved it so very much and
here's what i come up with
yeah there was like
what a jealous [ __ ] young kevin smith
was
but young kevin smith
is not
um
let's how do i put this i grew up in a
big catholic family so i went to a lot
of [ __ ] funerals
but of relatives that were like my
my mom and dad's uncles and [ __ ] like
that like older people who i didn't
really [ __ ] know or we saw once a
year
so i
i really wasn't
like familiar
with grief
you know i had my heart quote unquote
broken and [ __ ] in high school or
whatever the [ __ ] but like
i had never lost
anybody
close to me you know and even when my my
grandmother died in like 1997
and i was close to her but like i'd
already started the film journey so i
was already kind of out in the world and
whatnot and she'd been wanting to go for
like 12 years 12 years she was blind and
she was like i'd go over her house and
i'd be like hey graham what's up because
we just play cards all the time
but she couldn't after she couldn't see
couldn't do anything couldn't cook
couldn't crochet she just sat there and
she'd be like well i keep asking him to
take me but he won't come he won't take
me i was like
and she's like jesus i keep
asking him to take me home and she just
sat there for 12 years waiting
to die
so [ __ ] sad um
so
my my grandma who i grew up we were
right around the block from our growing
up is a very close relationship um i
wouldn't say we had a multi-generational
household like my kid grew up in like my
kid had two sets of parents me and my
wife and my wife's parents because
they've always lived with us um but we
you know they lived right around the
block my grandparents and so
very close relationship that all being
said
when my grandmother died i wasn't like
grief-stricken i was like well
she was 86 or 88 right my god she
she wanted to go for a long [ __ ] time
like i get it
so i've you know i watch that movie now
and
i know grief
i've lost people that i love um and and
when i say people i include [ __ ]
animals in that
list i know some people be like you're
an [ __ ] but it's like if you've never
had a pet you don't understand it is
literally like having a child
particularly if you raise that pet
from pup to the end
suddenly a fixture in your life
the best possible kid one don't [ __ ]
talk back
and they're fun
like suddenly you know
they're
they're they're just
gone and that's family i don't give a
[ __ ] what people say so
i i like as i was grieving what i knew
was coming we knew that marty was gonna
you know have an appointment the doctor
was gonna come to our house
we knew we were getting marty filet
mignon the night before in the morning
of like the day before that and that's
when we were watching magnolia so when
i'm watching jason robards die in the
movie and i'm looking at my dog
who i know is [ __ ] not gonna she
gonna see one more morning
maybe two no two more mornings and then
that's it
uh that's grief son and that movie and
i'm a big grief junkie like i [ __ ]
loved wandavision for that very reason
sure oh my god it was so it was grief
porn man i love when people are sad no
no i don't like to make them sad but i
love stories about
people that are
heartbroken that have to get over things
and whatnot um and i don't know why i've
always loved it it's always very
romantic notion even before i was
acquainted with the notion of what true
grief was
but i was into movie grief you know like
oh my heart's been stolen or oh she died
and [ __ ] she'll never live again
melodrama melodrama thank you paul
thomas anderson presents in magnolia
adult grief and i was even though i was
29
when i watched the movie
i was not yet an adult i was still an
infantilized [ __ ] teenager who got a
career at an early age so
what did i know about being an adult one
of the reasons you don't see me [ __ ]
mouthing off about
politics and how the world should be run
i
you know i ain't normal i get it like
from an early age somebody was like
here
you get a [ __ ] ticket out of this
[ __ ] you don't have to work you have
to struggle i mean your work you were
gonna do anyway
and you're never gonna have to wake up
and be like how am i gonna [ __ ] feed
my family and [ __ ] you're gonna be able
to feed your family by saying [ __ ] right
think about that so like when it comes
to that
i don't feel the need to tell people how
the world should be run i don't work in
the real world i live in [ __ ] fantasy
i literally
live in [ __ ] fantasyland now
so at that point like
as i watched
paul's movie the first time
i was like literally still a kid even
though i was 29 even though i had a
child of my own
i was not mature playing think about it
you know you can point chasing amy but
that's a grown-up movie but it's like
yeah but it's a grown-up movie about a
guy he's tony stark he created his own
problem and he solved it he's like i'm a
dick
and now i'm not
you know learn some lessons yeah and
that's kind of what life's about but so
i was in a much better position to
receive that movie sure doesn't change
the fact that the movie was great then
it's not like and now it's good because
i grew up it was great then i just
couldn't see the greatness because i
couldn't identify with grief now i can
identify with grief
and that movie i will go to that movie
more often
than i have in my entire life i will
watch magnolia again before the year
ends as my prediction
because there are some parts of it that
are so [ __ ] sad and i love that [ __ ]
dude i mean you see me i post pictures
me crying i
love to [ __ ] cry i mean every thread
in that movie
has something gut wrenching
my whole thing i you know i i always
want to watch it
let me amend that keep going i don't
love to cry i love to cry at art sam
it's very specific i don't have to cry
like in the real world and [ __ ]
because generally if you do
it's because some heartbroken happen
heartbreaking happens or something you
can't [ __ ] fix like you see a
homeless problem and you're like huh i
ain't talking about that crying i don't
like that crying it happens but like
that's not my [ __ ] porn my porn is
like i'm watching a movie or a [ __ ]
tv show or listening to a song i love
songs about people that are like bereft
and broken-hearted and i have no
real
identity factor with them like i don't
you know i
went through typical high school
breakups and [ __ ] like that but i'm
married for over like 20 years like i
don't there's not one that got away
i'm still [ __ ] the one so it's like
she likes you too he seems to dig me
enough to like keep this [ __ ] going
third person
perspective it
doesn't seem a way there's an insider
perspective right there but no beard
that one that's what jake's saying
but like you know so i don't have like
oh i love this because i went through
this i don't know why it's just my
[ __ ] kink like like that's what does
it for me
funny things don't do it for me because
and i don't want this to sound arrogant
or gross but i can make myself laugh
right just by having conversations with
my [ __ ] friends i get that [ __ ] for
free all the time that's not impressive
to me impressive is like you know
[ __ ] making a motherfucker's mood
change
drawing an emotion out of somebody with
lies bro
i mean that's all a movie and a tv show
and a song is even if they're biopics or
biopics it's all [ __ ] lies and if you
can manipulate that's magic words right
there if you can manipulate the audience
like that and make me a guy who's
sitting down the guy who's seen behind
the curtain and literally knows how
movies are [ __ ] made and [ __ ] like
that and you could still [ __ ] sucker
me you could still take me to a
different [ __ ] place
you could these [ __ ] could have been
charging me so much more for movies my
whole life the way that people play like
i'll pay a thousand dollars to fly to
egypt i pay you a thousand dollars you
make a [ __ ] movie that makes me
[ __ ] cry you charge me more than the
standard 10 [ __ ] bucks like if it
brings that out in me man like that's a
beautiful beautiful emotion that i've
always landed from childhood
based on nothing it's not based on like
when i was a kid i was broken or i lost
my parents i'm bruce wayne not at all my
parents like were happily married stayed
married i used to watch my mom
oh sh
my
you have a phone call soon
yeah at what time is it it is noon right
now
that's what that alarm was wait what is
the phone call
the phone call is
the peacock phone call that's been moved
that's been moving you didn't get that
information
we'll just leave it there we copy you
well that's what that was i'm sorry
there was an alarm for that that was the
alarm field yeah the only that was the
only thing i really on the schedule
today until leroy ron lands at noon
and then he comes to the house but
before that is noon now so leron should
be here in the next hour i'm going to
turn off these alarms so that they don't
go off good well done but uh but the
the other thing got moved they had to
move it not us so anyway
so i'm i'm [ __ ] dumbfounded by how
much i
love this movie magnolia and you know
i'm crying through it my wife is just
like you know what did you write about
it i'm like [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
i'm just eating [ __ ] [ __ ] but i don't
care because it moves me and anything
that moves me gets my [ __ ]
approval yeah moves me to tears if it
moves me in a way where and very few
things do
like where i watch a thing where and it
makes me you know like upset and not
upset because it's like the content but
just like come on what the [ __ ] you know
like yeah that don't happen too much
anymore i just i probably don't engage
with as many things like turn it off
drive around yeah draw the reaction
that's the thing we say in this house
all the time we always read the should
we watch it and we struggle over it for
a few minutes and we're like
i'll watch it and if we don't like it
we'll turn it off after [ __ ] 20
minutes yeah good point all right let's
dive in and it found many wonderful
things that went so
that all being said
the stage is set to watch licorice pizza
because i've now watched magnolia and
i'm like oh my god
i mean i always knew paul was a great
filmmaker but i'm like oh my god
you know my old white whale from the
late 90s early aughts what a horrible
way to begin the 2000s no wonder [ __ ]
went all downhill
um you know you can draw a direct line
oh my god totally
i'll show you a van [ __ ] diagram or a
flow chart
of that comment to like [ __ ] here
hear me sitting here podcasting for a
living 2016.
so
um
i i go and watch licorice pizza with the
wife
and
the two
one of the best the first things i can
say about this movie that i thought was
one of the best aspects was
it's cast like an like an episode of
degrassi
you know what i'm saying like all the
leads look like normal ass [ __ ]
people right the one who's the lead boy
uh cooper hoffman cooper hoffman who i'm
watching the whole movie and i'm like
where'd he find this normal ass
[ __ ] this is young kevin smith
as if i was doing a biopic of kevin
smith i [ __ ] cast this guy
at the end of the movie jennifer goes to
philip seymour hoffman's kid and i was
like what and she was like she just
looked it up because she too was like
wow this kid's impressive it's a real
family affair the whole movie is a real
family i'm glad i didn't know that going
in though good because i just got to
perceive this guy as an actor and not
like he's the [ __ ] son of one of my
favorite actors one of the only things i
knew about the film i didn't know [ __ ]
about it except the title and that he
owns the valley right now i go to the
valley a lot you cannot avoid licorice
i've never seen a movie poster
where the director's name is above the
title without a credit it just says paul
thomas anderson licorice pizza as though
he's nicolas cage
it's i've never seen it before and i'm
sure it's only here but um
that's a new goal
director's rock star um
the cast
is uh
not just like uh real looking which is
what i was extolling the virtues of they
look like real ass people yeah
you could get
so [ __ ] easily
lost in the story because you're not
like well
you know i saw him in star wars
and her now i understand she's like a
musician so perhaps whole family is
whole families and her sisters are in
the movie and her parents their parents
as well that's why i saw that in the
credits
so you know one if you were a big fan
like my friend malcolm ingram's huge
[ __ ] what is it called i'm a fan so
that's why he wants to go see licorice
pizza he's like i [ __ ] love him he
went to see him in concert a couple
times
you know i i'm aware that they were
artists but i i'm not i couldn't tell
you a song exactly so i didn't go in
with a pre-judged notion of like you
know
who she thinks she is
the singer you know i'm like this
[ __ ] is an actress
that [ __ ] is an actor
and they look as real as raincoats they
don't look hollywood at all and he shot
this [ __ ] in the valley
and there are hollywood [ __ ] people
in it
like bradley cooper one of the most
famous [ __ ] people on the planet
whether he's himself or a [ __ ]
raccoon
and he's in the movie playing john
peters
which i didn't [ __ ] know until you
brought it up before i saw licorice
pizza
uh jake was like hey man did you hear
and i was like what he's like well in
there's mo spoilers if you haven't seen
liquor's pizza it's not deep spoiled it
doesn't ruin the movie but there's a
moment in licorice pizza where
the john peters character who calls
himself john peters and describes
exactly that looks like him and says he
is dating barbra streisand and says her
name at least 20 times as he tries to
make the kid pronounce it
he
is talking to the kid
and he says um you know
you we get each other you and you know
what [ __ ]
luke knows this line
dead on i i got it i took a screen shot
because i was like what the [ __ ]
i was so delighted even though i knew it
was coming
i was absolutely uh delighted i was i
told jenna i was like i gotta pause this
she was like how did that happen
[Laughter]
i don't i'll tell you how i think it
happened here god damn it where's that
picture and the fact that i got to tell
you is one of the great delights of my
life i i took the l on the spoiler so i
could let you know because i wanted to
be the one to tell you he says we speak
the same language huh we're both from
the streets
now
you know i told that [ __ ] superman
story for years on evening with kevin
smith at colleges and it's on the
internet and stuff
and i talked about john peters and for
years
for generation
i was the the
guy the only person talking about john
peters he was a figure of [ __ ] myth
you did how did this get made and talked
about it as well until john schnepp made
the documentary
uh the death of superman lives what
happens
and he [ __ ] filmed
the late john schnepp the big big sweaty
god rest his soul
western power my big friend
uh my sweaty friend um he
he made this wonderful documentary where
he like literally
legitimized every story i ever told
about the superman experience in talking
about john peters he put john peter's
current day john peters or then current
day john peters on camera
and john peters ex acted exactly sounded
exactly and said the exact same things
that i said he said like for [ __ ] 10
20 years
it was a story that i told and a lot of
people like a couple you're just blowing
this up man you're like you're
exaggerating nobody's that weird and i'm
like
you can see right now and just talk so
here's this moment
in licorice pizza where
he the character of john peter says
we're from the streets which is
legit something that he said to me and
that i said in that story every time i
told it but of course mostly on the
evening with kevin smith the clip that's
online and how i as a
20 i'm 34 now
as a 34 year old associate john peters
like mostly with you in that story right
you know you know when you hear john
peters you're not like star is born
batman you know like it's pretty much i
got evening when i was 16 for my
birthday dave gave me that and uh
immediately watched it you know what i
mean and it's like that's some epic [ __ ]
uh those stories i've been hearing for
20 years now and so it's fun to be here
at the tail end of that and you're going
like wait there's a conclusion there's a
serious arc work bring your mic even
closer oh sorry there's some serious
bring it to you you don't have to do it
i like moving to it just get it as close
as you need otherwise people are going
to be like why is he so [ __ ] low
we're learning i'm learning all right
to be fair i wasn't like this wasn't
planned we had a minute so i was like
jake let's quick do a podcast
um
the uh who
who
who's the what's the girl's name the
heim girl's name alana alana heim i
believe wonderful yeah and
and
like
more of that man just cast like [ __ ]
real ass looking people um people that
look like people and that's not saying
like she's not pretty she's [ __ ]
stunning in a girl next door
kind of valley way yeah but she you know
clearly doesn't look like most the
person that hollywood normally casts
i hear he knows the family or grew up
around them that's what i'm to
understand like that he had a crush on
the mom when he was a kid
and then grew up and so like the fact
that it's philip seymour hoffman's kid
and then like this whole family he's
really doing something and i have no um
proof on this but i've heard him talk
and he was such a big fan of once upon a
time in hollywood and i was like i know
he's like i saw that movie like nine
times in the theater or something like
that and i just knew that like
structurally
it was gonna be kind of
loose
it like he was gonna do his kind of
version of that
uh is what i always kind of assumed
about time in the valley yeah but it's
like also like
with the
severe racism and like the hiving to
hide your love and
things of the era that really struck him
and but it is this it's my favorite kind
of a structure where you have two main
people
and then you just go from place to place
to place to place and you can have big
names
be there for 10 minutes and then
disappear i love that [ __ ] and these two
guys carry this movie very very
beautifully it meanders in in the the
most magical way yes you know this is
not like a block driven movie it's like
if they don't get to licorice pizza by
friday night at midnight
and lose their virginity
can you imagine oh my god
what a boring movie that would be the uh
i don't know just thinking like maybe i
should write that oh my god
let's talk about
uh the ending and this is where
if you're if you haven't seen the movie
maybe you jump out of this point of the
discussion copy you are forewarned
spoilers kids big time spoilers we're
gonna spoil the ending
of licorice pizza
so
get out if you don't want to hear it but
this is a
conversation with having
in five
four
three two one licorice pizza is
primarily concerned about the
relationship between a 25 year old
uh woman and a 15 year old young man
let's be honest boy yeah
and the boy is an entrepreneur and he's
sharp and he's he's smarter than the
average bear and he's not the average 15
year old and whatnot and he's got a line
and a wrap but he's
genuinely caring um
he's authentic even in his offense in
even in his inauthenticity because he's
a salesman
but
you could tell
he knows he's got something special a
genuine charisma yeah fair enough
absolute genuine charisma
but again ages 25 and 15. so it's you
know it's being sold as a coming-of-age
movie
and i was like oh well once i got the
once she said she was like 25 or once
her age was revealed i was like oh it's
he's in love with an older woman like
you know this they they used to make
these movies like you know it's not like
a trope that hasn't been a story that
hasn't been told before but i was trying
to fit it into a box that's what i do
when i watch a movie instantly like
where's this going
put it in try to pre-guess the narrative
probably has a lot to do with being a
writer as well
so
as i'm watching it
i'm like well this is going to be
star-crossed because
you know he's 15
and she's 25.
and
in the movie she's presented other male
options
throughout the entire movie yeah it's
kind of what the journey seems to be
where you're like basically she hangs
out with him and she's fascinated by him
and thinks he's funny and weird and like
all right and they become friends
and he's in love with her right and
co-workers and they they they team
business together they scheme together
they have fun together make money
together
um
unabashedly in love with her and she
interacts with other with older men
who
i mean there's a few her own age and
then older men as well
and every
like
me there's no
guy
ultimately
that
she enjoys
as much as this 15 year old kid right so
the movie has a very cinematic romantic
ending shot again here comes the [ __ ]
spoiler train so get out five four three
two one spoilers at
where they're running they're walking on
two different streets and wind up on the
same [ __ ] street in a very cinematic
romantic way run at each
other into each other's arms
and kiss
am i worried i don't know if they kiss
i don't remember um they might kiss
is the the enemy they definitely say i
love you
she says i love you and the
what all right
i read that
as not like buddy
and punching him in the arm right i read
that as a romantic
as did i relationship and i don't think
we're wrong
no now i'm not you know [ __ ] getting
all
like uh
conservative about it being like a 25
year old woman a 15 year old boy this is
[ __ ]
pederasty or whatever the [ __ ] this 1973
movie and it's a movie these people are
[ __ ] real
but my point to jake was like
just when
something like i really loved licorice
pizza like i said like took it was like
watching bad news bears for me and their
two movies couldn't be further apart and
plot
but the vibe and the feel
just i
i relaxed into it the same way i relax
into
the bad news bears and probably the way
i relax into the bad news bears now
racism aside
casual racism aside is um
because it takes me back to my childhood
where i'm like that's what the world
looked like when i was a kid and
licorice pizza though set in a
completely different part of the country
you know
in a world where movie stars literally
walk the streets and knock over garbage
cans
or movie producers rather
movie stars jump motorcycles yup
um
you know
i still recognize it just like i didn't
recognize the world fully of the bad
news bears
because it was daylight out for so long
where they lived
you know i was like it's seven o'clock
why how is it still light out there
um
so i i luxuriated in this movie i loved
it
that being said i said to jake i'm like
they race into each other's arms
and [ __ ] like indicate that there's
going to be a relationship and then the
credits happen yeah i'm like no
[Laughter]
the that what i didn't see that coming
that's that i did not predict that movie
and that's how you're gonna end the
movie like no
always a good sign if you want more
i doubt it's a movie he'll ever
sequalize
um and it's you know as a filmmaker i'm
sure he's like hey man you get to decide
what happened he makes a hundred million
dollars with it
then they'll make a sequel for it i
don't even know i i don't even know if
they will he doesn't seem like that guy
he
no he doesn't he doesn't he's a journey
man
he moves on and
[ __ ] you know he did his he did bro
how easy and low hanging fruit and
there's a clerks three guy talking would
it be for paul thomas anderson to make
you know
[ __ ] boogie nights two set in the
current world of porn where [ __ ]
those characters who were young in the
70s or old and in charge now or whatever
[ __ ] like god i know you know what i'm
saying so easy
but he don't he
boogie nights resurrection
oh nice clever title we're working on
your giraffe better
um it was uh yeah it was the one moment
in the movie where i was like what the
[ __ ] like
i i i'm not saying one move movement in
the movie where i didn't predict it or
something but like i didn't i did not
see that coming he always and i i have
always been in a 70s kind of way also
reminding me of like
movies in that moment
harold and maude yep
uh which is my favorite movie of all
time
really uh it's that
up there it's on my like you know i
don't have a number one of those
on my top five kind of all the ashby's
that's where you i mean it's just it
hits me yeah uh but last detail is very
very special
what about um um the landlord is very
special about being there is very
special i've only seen that like once
and it's like
it speaks
sometimes movies speak too close all
right and it's like
whoa and just kind of i like to let it
kind of live where it lives but
i mean creepy yet innocent deliveries of
a line of all time i made yourselves
like i like to watch eve right it's the
original i am
[ __ ] masturbating in front of him and
he watches the climax of the film
it's a literal climax it's an amazing
movie paul feels
uh paul tom sanderson feels like a
a part of that
yeah school of that legacy not even like
oh he's biting off ashby he feels like
he could stand shoulder shoulder he
feels like he's making a movie like
ashby would he just always feels like
he's making a movie from a better time
when people respected cinema more right
it's when people say like
um oh nolan's the closest thing we have
to kubrick i'm like
like yes and no
personally um
but it is that kind of
it's they're aiming for this trajectory
and they i do feel like they kind of
work shoulder to shoulder i just lost
the threat on that one
i was just people say that nolan nolan's
trying to do cooper
yeah maybe that's just me maybe i like i
mean i just love him so much and that's
it feels to me like nolan's trying to do
nolan i don't look at his career and
ever be like oh he's kind of like this
guy like he's he's kind of like an ang
lee where it's like
try to
try to pigeonhole hang lee
as a director [ __ ] jumps from
style to style from substance to
substance like
there's no like oh he makes hang lee
movies it's like we'll [ __ ] define
what that is same thing with chris nolan
i i don't know what a chris nolan movie
because really because he changes it
every time i mean i know there are going
to be certain elements that are you know
i feel like there's like a there's a
certain
what's the word a sheen or a patina to
uh other than the score because i mean
yeah they're pretty uniform throughout
but no just like each other
so
he does do a different thing but they're
also he um he's another one that i have
a hard time because he doesn't throw in
a lot of humor into like any of his
movies i don't mind that he's got dry
jokes [ __ ] michael came and cracked
the joke yeah
oh there's always two dry jokes like
and i get it you need you need to break
the tension
and he's just one of those writers
that's like
i don't i don't you can't see me but
it's kind of
a heavy hand holding a heavy hammer
thunking over and over you know what i
mean like i this is the theme of the
film
and i i never
i don't know if i get that out of a
chris nolan movie maybe i'm making um
maybe always reveals every every frame
every scene
everything just feels important
like in a way where i make movies and it
feels so frivolous
and everything he does
just seems important even when it's
movies where you're like i don't know
what happened but that seemed important
like
interstellar was baffling to me where i
was like
see that's my problem with christopher
nolan is i have a hard time with
re-watchability interstellar is one of
the weird ones interstellar and dunkirk
for some reason i can watch those guys
a lot what about [ __ ] the batman
stuff dark knight dark knight rises um
batman begins no
it's not that i have to watch this weird
personal relationship with those movies
i lived in chicago when the dark knight
was being shot i had friends at my
college that worked on that set
i
heard nothing
about anything else but [ __ ] batman
every single day
every single hour for three years and
then the second the movie came out they
were like immediately talking about the
next one who are they gonna cast and i
remember being in class and being like
you guys need to stop and you need to
let the man rest
let him sleep for a [ __ ] second
before you start talking about philip
seymour hoffman as the riddler in batman
3. you've never made me want to be a
chicagoan an illinois
person that is
me for my generation too was this where
this was happening where you were like
everyone around you was stu where were
you yeah i was in chicago i went to
columbia college chicago in the south
loop just knowing that i could have sat
around and talked about batman with
people working on batman
i'd have given up all this kevin you can
do that i do it on podcast no but you
can go to any film school in the entire
world and go talk about batman and
everyone will want to know but talk
about batman with people who worked on
batman i would have been getting all
sorts of inside stories and [ __ ] there
was a good story from my buddy fred
glander
uh
uh who said that he'd be twice be
careful no he he saved
the camera he saw um
like a 18 wheeler going toward the
camera
and he [ __ ] jumped in between and
they stopped the
the truck
and he was a [ __ ] pa
and um he said that christopher nolan
came over to him shook his hand thanked
him and everything like that that kind
of thing i had a friend who is uh
another pa who's like i just remember
heath ledger being like skateboarding
everywhere with his hoodie on with
makeup but just skateboarding everywhere
you know like just a lot it was all
it's so
seminal it's so
like
i don't know what it is but it i mean
it i'm also
i'll be perfectly frank with you kevin
my favorite batman movie is batman
forever
wow
look we'll save that for a batman show
okay no i know but this is where i don't
have to defend it but this is where i'm
coming from where it's like ultra
serious batman versus [ __ ] joel
schumacher doing
whatever the [ __ ] he's doing then uh
sidebar then where is your how do you
feel about the zack snyder batman
i just watched justice league for the
first time the long one the long one
hold on
hold that we'll do a whole episode about
that
you got to get luke on here yeah done
and done
you got to get luke out here um um
that's who i'll be i'll continue to do
the show with uh kids
on a regular basis uh
we'll be doing jake we'll be doing luke
with vinnie pereira when he's out here
yeah
um but we're just gonna geek out on
[ __ ] film
can you call him reviews i don't know
um
but that [ __ ] licorice pizza
make time for it sean penn plays william
holden i don't i don't know if like
i think the things we said about the
movie prior to this probably sell it
better than that i don't know if anybody
out there is like oh well now i'm going
tom waits plays john ford yes and that's
that's a draw tom waits alone is a draw
i think that john ford john ford is that
who he is meant to play i think so i
think he's a proxy like a john ford
proxy
um
the
you know we were just talking about
network which is another episode um but
that's a movie that's very popular for
these short performances that win awards
uh without giving anything away i think
the audition scene whoever plays that
the woman who's in the audition who's
also in phantom thread i think she
should be nominated for everything
because i think that scene is [ __ ]
incredible hold on hold on what does the
audition say they just they stay on her
face
and talks about she just talks about uh
elena's alana's like face
and her big jewish nose and stuff like
that that lady that lady i think that
scene was so
good
and i and you think that's you think she
should get it between her and pooper
yeah cooper is just uh wait but the lady
who said that [ __ ] she's only in that
one scene just in that one scene so
you're like equating that to like the uh
[ __ ] lumet
network where francis sternhagen is it i
believe or uh i know
she's the one who won who won for she's
um william holden's
wife in networking
yeah um who you know has like 10 minutes
in the movie but that and eight of them
are that [ __ ] scene oh and it's just
unreal and and out acts everybody in
motion pictures that you right she's
amazing and then baby got nominated for
another 10 minute scene where he just
knocks out of the park but he did one
day at work and then he didn't win but
he got an oscar not for it in your
estimation the lady who goes at her
about like oh my god you've got your
what a jewish nose yeah she could get a
nod now in a world of justice now that
we're talking about it
i that's what i thought when i watched
it right i'm not saying defense no i
just know i just
love
when you're not afraid to just stay on
someone's face and watch someone act
like she's acting
so much but it's not overacting she's
just [ __ ] killing it it's just what i
like to see and if you know her she
plays the drunk in phantom thread which
i know you haven't seen but it's one of
the funnier kind of sequences where
they're like
they don't like her and they have to
make she she's so rich they have to make
her a dress but they don't like her
personality so they don't want to make
her a dress
and uh just as far as showing up in a
scene
and having an extreme close-up on your
face
and just knocking it out of the park i i
love her i should look up her name so
that i can
like give her proper credit um yeah good
[ __ ] here we are going like man such
an [ __ ] this is my favorite part of
the movie
you're literally campaigning for her
oscar
is um phantom thread
uh
do you like it a lot should i i do like
it a lot it's a very very different film
but i i do like it a lot i did show it
to my lady bones thinking that she would
like it and she did not like it because
she knew too many dudes that are like
uh daniel day lewis he's just uh he's
such a [ __ ] artist is it lady bones
is her name bones her name is hillary
i call her bones
um i just didn't know if you were like
my lady bones like that was your
nickname oh that's funny no i
accidentally called her my lovely bones
and i said i'm never going to do that
again that's not a good important
so uh but if i just talk about you know
bones no one knows no one knows what
you're talking about why are they
putting this in order of
uh
of their appearance but yeah i mean i
guess you can't just be like the lady
who said just [ __ ] about jewish noses
[Laughter]
harriet sampson harris let me show me a
picture when you got one
because i
remember the scene
i've seen her in something else too well
let's
yeah [ __ ] i'm like boy if only i can
remember
the first titles are uh adam's family
values
nurse betty momento
um
[Music]
oh wait american ladies desperate
housewives
that's a good question i didn't watch
this scroll and see
scrolling
supergirl played sinead on supergirl
yes 28 episodes felicia tillman on
desperate housewives um yeah
the shield tick on that show no she's
one but i love her as an actress she's
she's like like steven root
the [ __ ] cartilage of the business
and you don't know her name what's her
name
wow
we're already [ __ ] harriet sansom
harris because that doesn't even sound
familiar to me like like this the double
the samsung is is a lot right so harriet
harris harriet harris um yeah man she's
magic in all the movies and all the tv
shows you ever seen her in she's just
like she's like a root where you're just
like jeez man like always happy
yeah and and
never dropping the ball never
um
yeah man it's uh
seek out licorice pizza let's talk about
that title because that's the discussion
we had yesterday sure they never once
say
i mean spoilers they never once say
licorice pizza and they don't be they
don't go to licorice pizza and i well i
said to jake i was like what's that
title about
and jake said the original title was
soggy bottom which is what he tries to
name the business the first time yeah
before it's fabulous
before it becomes fat bernie's
um
so uh i said why is it so why liquor's
pizza and
uh jake was like i think there's a store
in the valley called licorice pizza in
the 70s what
we [ __ ] googled it i just googled why
licorice pizza
why
why
and sure enough it was like licorice
pizza was a couple record stores in the
valley
circa like the 70s and
i think jake summed it up because i was
like why would you call it that he was
like i think it's kind of like brazil
you know yeah just call a thing a thing
even though i don't ever say the type of
thing
it's the thing that inspires the thing
i've gotten [ __ ] for it in my titles
when i've written things like in college
i remember someone getting really angry
about it i'm like [ __ ] you it's fine
where can they see your work can they
see your work somewhere wow
jellyrollchicago.com there you go do it
again
jellyrollchicago.com all all one word
and that's your site that's everything
there is it links to my youtube um i got
a couple of scripts on there
um uh oh you just opened up the [ __ ]
door man people are like all right now
razer fan script that i wrote with my
buddy nate oh my god which is fun and
filthy it's filthy a lot of sex oh my
god it's the filthiest [ __ ] that i could
find i'll tell you man that hell raiser
how old were you when you wrote it
a couple it was a few years ago
i feel like in my 30s it's about like
reverse cuckolding and stuff like that
there's all sorts of crazy [ __ ] it's
good it's good if you know
[ __ ] i'm like i'm like you write the
horror [ __ ] i want to write the perverse
sex stuff because that's why i like
hellraiser because it's [ __ ] perverse
that what i remember how razer like i
watched
i watched telrazer with kim locker and
my my high school girlfriend and you
know in hellraiser
um
the
brother
the wife
kills the husband
or lets the husband get killed by the
cenobites or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah because she's [ __ ] the brother
yeah and the brother comes back to life
and she starts doing
his bidding yes so she's a very sexy
movie for being like
full of blood full of leather and full
of chains barker very clyde parker
stevens was stephen king doesn't feel
the need to sex [ __ ] up he just makes
them you know
horror creepy spooky his sexy version is
like rebecca de mourney in the shining
mini series oh wow good poll uh but
[ __ ] clyde barclays that should be
scott barger is like
we're gonna lay some sex in this i
remember sitting there next to kim
locker and being so out like in a chat
remember the scene in chasing amy where
holden is like you know
so finger cuffs what's that about
[ __ ] like
baiting her and beating her until she
breaks and [ __ ]
i remember watching el razor with kim
locker and being like oh man it sucks
like i don't like that i hate that i
hate that like
he cheat she cheated with his brother or
she cheated at all don't you hate that
and you know i think she was like wait
what's the answer here am i supposed to
say i'll never cheat with your brother
donald
that was before we knew donald was gay
but still like
um yeah that was
it was such a sexy movie that it created
an argument between
young 16 17 year old lovers you like
this this that was my reaction to when
my ex showed me bridges of madison
county and she said it was the sexiest
movie of all time and i was like but she
just is cheating the whole time
her husband works hard i know he's
boring you got kids did you happen to
write a fanfic script sequel to that
you're so pretty much so no but the
others are that's on my website i let
one my one friend took care of like you
know the old-timey dialogue i brought
the sex no i go i go through when i
write my scripts it's like this is my
funny one this is my uh
my romantic one this is my very violent
one this is my on my filthy just un
obscenely filled with wobbly ages
madison county yeah um and then the
other fan script that i do have there i
do have some original stuff that i might
take off um but
uh is a colombo fan script that i'm very
very proud of
i wrote a feature-length columbo movie
what does a youngster like yourself know
about [ __ ] columbus this is my
favorite really oh my god don't get me
started
are you were you raised like [ __ ] uh
wanda maximoff like with old-timey
videotapes and [ __ ] dvds and some
foreign i am the youngest of five in
sokovia
in vermont
i'm the youngest of five
um i grew up on your [ __ ] in the
simpsons what you're reborn 1987. oh the
simpsons that'll do it you know and
somebody watching that
[ __ ] are like you you forget
right how much of pop culture they built
is crazy i know
i can talk to you about adlai stevenson
or lee iacocca that or judge you know
those are my favorite kinds of jokes i
don't like simpsons or just because it
it because of
i like the disposable nature of early
90s like
[ __ ]
uh
jokes like that i don't know like it's
just something that tickles me for some
reason so
it's that and also um
you know i used to be really obsessed
with the fact that my dad lived in
new york in brooklyn and manhattan from
19 he went to high school in 1966
and graduated college in 1974. and i was
like that's just what i
want before i realize that i actually
want to live in the future and so where
i'm at is actually the best place that's
weird my kid
was always like oh man i wish i [ __ ]
grew up in the 90s or whatever [ __ ] and
i was like you didn't or the 80s yeah i
grew up in the 80s and i was there from
the 90s
and i was like um i don't know like you
guys i feel like you guys got it better
now you get the [ __ ] over it and that's
why i'm like i'm excited because there's
a lot of 70s fashion and like that's why
i'm growing out my beard and [ __ ] like
that and like people have funny hair
right now and i'm like it's all the
great things about the 70s but with
phones it's on the internet there's a
very cervical beard you got going on
thank you i'm i'm working on it i don't
know
we'll see what happens um
thank you that is that's like the nicest
compliment
to a kid who likes 70 [ __ ]
uh so there it is that's what we'll be
doing we'll be deep diving
on a [ __ ] in their movie um this
week of course we deep dove on paul
thomas anderson and his licorice pizza
and magnolia um but uh next week
we're in deep dive on adam mckay
and don't look up
yeah
um
the new
patti chayowski or sydney lumet
or
or the new kubrick
or
or
um
you know
the the
i'll be straight with you he's a guy
where i'm like that's adam mckay because
after recognizes stuff well yeah um
seeing anchorman in the theater was one
of the greatest experiences in my life
we can talk about that next time um
but
uh i
also like the run of movies between that
and the other guys yeah there was a
point where i out loud was like this guy
has more funny hits than mel brooks in a
row
i have to give him credit for what he's
doing and then he started doing the big
short and all this other stuff so like
i'm a fan that being said when we say
his name next to petty chairski
talk about butthole clenching i don't
[ __ ] like that because
that's like as a big network fan well as
a you know what
hold it till next week yeah that's when
you get to make your [ __ ] case
um i did not know that [ __ ] patty
chasky would be your trigger
your generation it's just it's
unpredictable
library i got really into him during the
pandemic marty's i wrote a movie that
stole the bones from marty
and it's just my own movie but it's
marty
i love it
hold that thought
next week we are going to deep dive on
adam mckay and uh and don't look up
which is on netflix right now so if you
don't want it spoiled for you next week
make sure you watch it already um and if
you're one of those people who's like i
don't know why i'm not [ __ ] political
[ __ ]
i personally don't find the movie very
political uh i i think it is an equal
opportunity offender and as much as it
makes fun of literally
everybody in all sides and if you're
allowed to say politics aside or like
you know uh the performances are just
top-notch it's just an incredible cast
this is almost spoiler since we'll talk
about that next week that's you're going
to hear a lot more about that next week
but just if you're there going like i
ain't getting involved in this political
[ __ ] i personally
i just didn't find it political
we'll talk about it next week but that's
just to let you know
if you've been on the fence about
watching it and you're like oh ain't
gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna we're gonna talk about it a
lot
and the things to talk about like
ironically aren't
you know
right left [ __ ] them us
i i just want to talk about this man's
comfort food maker yeah there's a lot of
movie stuff to talk about yeah oh my god
um because i'm a big short fan
um i ain't no little fan of the big
short thank you very much we're ending
with dad jokes
from a guy that had the edge with
[ __ ] gizmopper material on imdb that
attracted a young [ __ ] would-be
filmmaker to a guy making dad jokes in
front of the same would-be filmmaker
who's like how'd i get roped into this
[ __ ] please
i am thinking that but not with that
tone in my head
where is the uh address they can find
your stuff again
jellyrollchicago.com
jellyrollchicago.com
uh if you wanna look at jake's stuff if
you wanna look at my stuff i'm doing my
show awaken bake five days a week now
monday through friday
at that kevin smith club and we're doing
some cool things come on over to that
kevinsmithclub.com ladies and gentlemen
uh there it is kids uh
that uh that
is episode one of film school fridays uh
for this week i'm kevin smith i'm jks
weissman and you just been schooled
[Music]
this has been a smodco internet
production
sit
only at smodcast.com